en este vídeo vamos a pensar en los
ingresos marginales y el costo marginal
para una empresa en un mercado de
competencia imperfecta pero antes de
hacerlo solo quiero revisar y comparar
lo que ya sabemos sobre una empresa en
un mercado de competencia perfecta de
modo que justo aquí estamos analizando
la economía de la empresa se muestra el
costo marginal en función de la cantidad
y hemos hablado de esto antes a menudo
la tendencia bajará inicialmente ya que
tienes una mejor especialización y
algunas eficiencias y luego podría
comenzar a aumentar la tendencia ya que
hay costos de coordinación u otros que
hacen que el costo marginal aumente y ya
hemos hablado sobre esta noción de que
en un mercado de competencia perfecta la
empresa es precio aceptante habrá algún
precio de mercado
llamémosle sub m algún precio en el
mercado por el bien que producen y hay
muchos productores no hay diferenciación
en el producto y no hay barreras a la
entrada y por eso tienen que aceptar el
precio del mercado
no importa cuántas unidades produzcan
solo podrán obtener
el mismo precio de mercado así que en
una empresa en un mercado de competencia
perfecta ese precio de mercado define su
curva de ingresos marginales su curva de
ingreso marginal esencialmente será una
línea horizontal como ésta ya lo hemos
estudiado en vídeos anteriores y
hablamos de eso aquí si esta empresa
fuera racional e intentará maximizar su
ganancia produciría la cantidad donde el
costo marginal es igual al ingreso
marginal
así que produciría esta cantidad que
tenemos justo aquí pero ahora pensemos
en cómo las cosas son un poco diferentes
para una empresa en un mercado de
competencia imperfecta en un vídeo
anterior hablamos sobre cómo en un
mercado de competencia imperfecta hay
una cierta diferenciación en el producto
de las diferentes empresas que compiten
y por lo tanto su precio de mercado es
una función de la cantidad si producen
una gran cantidad de su producto el
precio que obtienen en el mercado
probablemente bajará así que tendrán su
propia curva de demanda específica de la
empresa tal vez se vea como algo así
y su curva de demanda y también vimos en
ese vídeo que esa curva de demanda es
esencialmente el precio que podrían
obtener en cualquier nivel de cantidad y
que no va a ser lo mismo que la curva de
ingreso marginal si la curva de demanda
es así con una pendiente descendente es
probable que la curva de ingreso
marginal sea aún más descendente así que
se vería como algo así esta sería la
curva de ingreso marginal ahora en esta
situación que sería racional que hiciera
la empresa bueno una vez más querría
producir la cantidad donde el costo
marginal es igual al ingreso marginal
así que ellos querrían producir esta
cantidad que tenemos aquí pero aquí
podemos ver algo interesante si producen
en esta cantidad observa que el precio
que pueden obtener en el mercado es
mucho más alto el precio que obtienen en
el mercado es más alto que el costo
marginal y el ingreso marginal en ese
punto
y la razón por la que vemos una
situación en la que el precio es mayor
que su costo marginal en contraste con
un mercado de competencia perfecta donde
se ve que el precio es igual al costo
marginal esa es la cantidad óptima pero
debido a esta brecha la gente está
dispuesta a pagar más en ese costo
marginal pero no podrías producir más
porque no tiene sentido desde un punto
de vista de ingresos marginales esta
brecha la diferencia entre el precio y
el costo marginal en esta cantidad de
producción racional para la empresa en
el mercado de competencia imperfecta los
economistas la llaman ineficiencia
ineficiencia la gente está dispuesta a
pagar más que ese costo marginal pero la
empresa no tiene motivación para
producir más porque si produce es más a
pesar de que el precio es más alto que
el costo marginal su ingreso marginal
estará por debajo del costo marginal por
lo que estarías recibiendo un costo
adicional sobre esas unidades extras
hasta el próximo vídeo